joins me now uh i suppose the first
question she must be how how are your
family in kabul what contact have you
been able to have with them
well it has been definitely difficult
for them the situation is every day
getting more dangerous and everybody's
so terrified everybody's just finding a
way to get away and unfortunately um i
have a difficult time reaching out my
parents i don't know if it is due to
internet or electric or
i have no idea but i am definitely
um really worried about everybody down
there it looks like people are so
terrified they're so scared
are they are your family trying to get
out as far as you know
um
well we are really trying
so
you can but hope that neil farr tell us
a little bit about
about your journey to where you are now
i mean becoming a pilot in the afghan
air force that uh you know despite the
fact that the taliban were not in power
that must still have been
extraordinarily difficult
very difficult you know
as an afghan female
of course this is something the talibans
are against the taliban warriors against
women they don't want a woman to be
educated educated they take away the
rights from the woman the first thing
they do they take away everything from a
woman the same thing i was the symbol of
freedom of women in afghanistan as a
woman that i raise my voice and try to
go against what they believe and
unfortunately it end up rest my life and
my family's life and i have been
threatened so many times by them my
brother got shot by them and it's it's
just
really really scary situation for any
woman to be in
and now right now and i'm thinking about
what every afghan females are going
through every little girl's or woman's
in afghanistan are going through
they must be really scared for their
life i have been watching videos i
cannot like take my mind away i have
been watching the news non-stop and my
heart is in pain watching the girls
screaming that i will get killed please
take me away or you know it's really
really scary that all the woman has to
think like this because they know what
their future is going to look like for
them
i spoke to a taliban spokesman a couple
of days ago and he said to me that the
taliban have changed that they believe
that women should be educated he said
that they could go to university he said
that women could work he also said the
women didn't need to wear the burqa
walking around afghanistan
do you believe him
i do not
i do not believe that the people that
they already prove themselves how the
world is easy believe them already that
they have changed they're the same
people already in kabul you see no sign
of any woman
any pictures of a woman in the stores
and the walls it has been already
blacked out there's no woman in the city
one woman already got killed because she
didn't have a burka on how can i even
trust that word how the world can trust
that word
what impact has it had on your family i
mean you wanted to
um become a pilot
it must have been a really really tough
journey you mentioned your brother being
shot
how have your family coped with with you
wanting a career
i have been always blessed to have them
in my life you know like since i decided
to do something for my country serve my
country and fly from my country and go
against what is not right for a woman
and be a woman to raise my voice against
all this
the wrong stuff that they believe
of course myself and my family been
always targeted because they don't like
a woman to raise their voice and ask for
their right and unfortunately you know
they always stood by me and it really
breaks my heart that now that situation
just me wearing the uniform serving my
country now putting entire my family in
rest it's really breaking my heart that
i'm thinking what i have done wrong
this is my fault that i wear the uniform
i tried to serve my country just because
i'm a woman they don't see me as a human
being
it's really really heartbreaking
what of your career you you managed to
go to america and you've managed to
continue to fly
what is your life like now
well um i'm so blessed to be able to fly
again back in the united states and um
everything has been great and um thank
god i am safe i'm not worried about my
safety and i'm trying to achieve more
more rights more voice raise my voice
for more women and girls that they have
been left behind in afghanistan and i
would try my best to do anything that if
i can save them because i know how that
feels to be in their place i have been
on that place seven years ago and i know
how that feels when you are you have no
support and everybody leaves you alone
including the society just for being a
woman
so i have been blessed that i have been
given the opportunity to raise again and
do what i have been dreamed to do
would you ever consider flying for the
american air force over afghanistan
absolutely
if i wear the uniform no matter here and
afghanistan i will be still proud to
wear the uniform and go and maybe one
day back to my country and serve my
country and save my people and that's
what i'm looking for and really looking
for that that day will
come soon
could you ever see a situation arise
though where you may be flying
for america against the taliban over
afghanistan
well
as an afghan woman that would be my
honor i would absolutely do it with not
even thinking too second about it
do you think you can ever go back to
afghanistan do you think you will do you
have any hope for the future
well it's hard you know afghan's been
hoping for years and years it's more
than decades every afghan every little
african
girls that now they are
probably 20 older than 20 they are
hoping that for the better future
unfortunately every time that we hope
for a better future it just disappoint
us it goes all the way
way back and you know as a little girl i
grew up during this 20 years of freedom
in afghanistan given every right to do
what i want to do and raise my voice and
fight for my country but i never thought
i never thought when i was a little girl
that this is going to be new afghanistan
and this is really scaring me that
seeing this is 20 years of
fighting the water all the lives
international lives has been lost in
afghanistan during this life 20 years of
war all those trillions trillions
dollars been spent
what happened to all of those what
happened it all wasted
how the world can abandon afghanistan
that quick
and that's what surprised me that how
afghanistan can go
back to the story that it was 20 years
ago
and i'm honestly i'm not saying i'm
gonna give up hoping but i will still
hope for the better future and the
better future for the girls and women in
afghanistan
are you angry at the american
authorities for pulling out i am not i
am not angry
i cannot say the world that afghanistan
they could stay in afghanistan forever
no nobody can stay anywhere forever and
i am more disappointed on my own afghan
government that they abandoned the
country because if the u.s pulled out
yes
they made a decision that they did but
why afghan government handed
20 years of freedom back to taliban you
know we have been actually you know i
have been hearing this that why afghan
troops didn't fight they did fight we
lost over 57 000 of soldiers and
fighting against taliban during all
these years because they had a backup
they had air support they had people
that they were supporting them along the
way they had a confident they were they
were thinking that there is somebody
having my back but now
when the leaders abandoning entire you
know the soldiers army
what they can do they cannot do anything
and that's the most disappointing for me